when you talk about stability
and you're going to talk about fortune
Uhm then I find it very complicated
because uh that man who ticks off voters
who ran screaming away from the party of labor
from mister milk
no stability
they found their Hail by fortune
it was then literally demonized into the grave
and 1 party came into the room as the largest
literally beheaded
with no leader
without control
mat herben still has every effort there
and coalition tried to forge
of 1 lot that has been effectively broken
that literally killed the leader
after voters ran away from the unstable
it has become stable
political words
so then we shouldn't come up with the story of god now
that is sincerely always so unstable and complicated
and there is no trust
that is 1 climate
what the hell now
is slept on the talk shows again